lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es que
veamos a los exponentes de una forma
ligeramente distinta que es más útil en
algunos contextos y bueno también quiero
hacer más ejemplos porque son muy útiles
para ver cómo funcionan las cosas en el
vídeo pasado vimos que elevar un número
a una potencia es básicamente agarrar
ese número y multiplicarlo el número de
veces que indica la potencia ok entonces
por ejemplo si tenemos menos 2 y lo
elevamos a la tercera potencia eso es
igual a tomar tres de estos menos dos
aunque entonces ponemos por aquí un
menos dos luego otro menos dos y
finalmente otro menos dos y multiplicar
los que no tenemos que para nada estamos
haciendo menos dos por tres
aquí más bien estamos agarrando este
número y lo multiplicamos por sí mismo
tres veces y eso lo que nos queda es
menos 2 x menos 2 que es pues menos x
menos nos va a dar más y 2 por 2 nos da
4 o sea que entre estas dos tenemos un 4
y luego multiplicamos ese 4 por menos 2
y entonces nos queda
por menos 28 menos 8 entonces menos 2 la
tercera potencia es menos 8 y la forma
super ligeramente distinta de pensar en
elevar a un número a una potencia que
vamos a usar es decir que un número
elevado a una potencia es igual a tomar
un 1 y multiplicar ese 1 por este número
la cantidad de veces que nos diga el
exponente aunque entonces si tenemos
menos 2 elevado a la 3 eso tiene que ser
igual a uno x uno menos 2 por otro menos
2 por otro menos 2 y bueno obviamente
estos dos son iguales o sea que esto es
igual a menos 8 porque multiplicar
cualquier cosa por un 1 es igual a esa
misma cosa entonces en realidad estas
dos definiciones son equivalentes ahora
porque le estamos agregando este 1 por
acá pues porque va a ser sub
útil cuando estemos tratando de elevar
un número a la potencia cero oa la
potencia 1 ok lo vamos a ver en unos
cuantos segundos ok
cuánto vale 2 elevado a la potencia cero
ok queremos encontrar cuánto vale 2 a la
0 pues lo que vamos a hacer es utilizar
esta definición y eso lo que nos dice es
que tenemos que poner un 1 por acá y
multiplicarlo por 20 veces aunque
entonces en realidad no tenemos que
multiplicar al 1 por nada así es que 2 a
la 0 es uno aunque bueno esto puede
parecer un poco no tan intuitivo pero
vamos a ver un poco más que hay de fondo
y porque realmente 2 a la 0 tiene que
ser 1 haber para practicar eso de tomar
un número y elevarlo a una potencia
vamos a ver cuánto vale 2 elevado a la
potencia 1
eso es igual a tomamos nuestro 1 y lo
multiplicamos por el 2 una sola vez
ok y entonces nos queda que 2 elevado a
la potencia 1 es 1 por 2 que es igual a
2 a ver a ver vamos a ver 2 elevado a la
potencia 2 eso tiene que ser igual a
pues tomamos un 1 y lo multiplicamos por
2 dos veces aunque entonces una vez dos
veces y eso es igual a 1 por 2 2 por 2 4
que y entonces vamos a tomar el 2 y lo
vamos a elevar a la tercera potencia y
eso es igual a tomamos el mismo 1 de
siempre y lo multiplicamos por 2
tres veces de una vez dos veces y tres
veces y eso es igual a 1 por 2 2 por 2 4
y por 2
eso es 8 este ya lo habíamos hecho
durante espero pues está bien volverlo a
hacer
y bueno tal vez puedes observar que hay
un patrón muy claro para pasar de 2 a la
0 a 2 a la 1 para pasar de este 1
este 2 podemos pensar que estamos
multiplicando por dos porque uno por 2
es 2 y luego para pasar de 2 a la 1 a 2
a las dos pues también podemos
simplemente multiplicar por 2 porque dos
por dos es cuatro y bueno en el fondo
eso es exactamente lo que estamos
haciendo porque dos al lado significa
que estamos tomando un 1 y multiplicando
por 2 2 veces pero si ahora lo que
queremos hacer es 2 a la 3 o sea agarrar
un 1 y multiplicar por 2 3 veces pues ya
lo único que nos falta
multiplicar por 12 más o sea todo este
pedazo es igualito a 2 a la dos y ya
simplemente nos falta multiplicar por 12
entonces para pasar de 2 a la 2 a 2 a la
3 sólo nos falta multiplicar por 2 está
muy bonito no pero bueno no sólo está
bonito también nos puede ayudar a
entender por qué dos a la 0 tiene que
ser igual a 1 y eso
lo podemos pensar de la siguiente forma
digamos que todavía no sabemos cuánto
tiene que valer 2 a la 0 sin embargo
pues nosotros sabemos que 2 a la 3 tiene
que ser igual a 8 y bueno también que
dos a la 2 tiene que ser igual a 4 y 2 a
la 1 tiene que ser igual a 2 pero bueno
podemos ver que para obtener 2 a la 2 a
partir de 2 a la 3 lo único que tenemos
que hacer es dividir a 2 a la 3 entre
dos y luego para encontrar 2 elevado a
la 1 tenemos que dividir a 2 elevado a
la 2 entre 2 para obtener 2 a la 1
entonces podemos pensar que para obtener
2 a la 0 a partir de 2 a la 1 lo único
que tenemos que hacer es dividir a 2 a
la 1 entre dos pero dos entre 2 es 1
entonces está muy bien eso de que 2
elevado a la cero sea igual a 1 pero
bueno en general esto se puede hacer
para cualquier número aquí no tiene por
qué ser un 2
5 millones puede ser 800 mil 553 el
chiste es que cualquier número distinto
de 0 elevado a la potencia 0 es igual a
1 y también cualquier número elevado a
la potencia 1 es ese mismo número